all right welcome to my basement work is
being done here's your big update I'll
explain to you what's happening we got
some guys working out here they're
laying down basically it's starting to
build a foundation getting everything
finished there's gonna be a lot of work
being done it's gonna be awesome
but this is just the beginning this is
day one so there's still a lot that
hasn't been done that needs to be done
but here's a view of what it looks like
and now let me zoom be walls here walls
here so you're not gonna be able to do
this in the future but there's gonna be
a nice little room here alright we're
gonna start doing podcasts in this room
and let me explain to you exactly what
the update is so I know a lot of people
are like what's going on with this
channel Tim you didn't produce well I'm
talking to people we're gonna be hiring
them and we're gonna be building this
stuff out it's gonna take a little bit
more than a month month and a half but
yes there's gonna be a lot of stuff
going on this is cool man I'm stoked
this is the first time I've come down
after they started you can see the wood
along the walls and you can see where
the doors are gonna be where the walls
are gonna be and now we're back again so
this morning I gave you that first
update then I did all my work and then I
came back down wow this is crazy look
how much they got done this is this is
amazing we're gonna have this is gonna
be I'm so excited you guys you have no
idea so listen I'm gonna I'm gonna give
you I'm actually gonna do a sit down and
give you a break under everything but I
wanted to do is I wanted to come down
when the guys first started work they've
already done the frame that's so amazing
and then I wanted to come back down once
they finished for the day I don't even
know if they're finished with it I don't
think they actually left all their stuff
here maybe was getting lunch or
something but I finished for the day and
so now I want to give you a rundown of
where we're at what's going on why it's
happening why there aren't more videos
remember that just a minute ago for you
I was walking through this now there's
rain that's so cool imagine this so
we're gonna have storage you can see the
furnace and all that but this big space
here look how much space we have it's
huge we're gonna have a set probably
over here maybe not because of the
windows but we're gonna figure it out
let me get out of here
let me go back to the the normal the
normal space or a normally fill and give
you guys an update on what's happening
with this channel and what you can
expect to see in the future so I'm back
up in my normal shooting space and I
want to give you guys
up.get and everything's happening so you
saw the basement look at how that work
that was done that was really really
cool and a lot of people are angry they
said Tim you did this van video and
you're gonna be doing all these things
you talked about going the border and
doing field journalism and then
something happened
well sub verse is doing really well and
we needed a space so we started looking
into purchasing a new office so that you
know it saves money in the long term and
yeah we want to set up an office so we
can start hiring people and working on
shows and podcasts and documentaries
unfortunately over the past couple
months I've been working on a couple
different options and they ended up
falling through at the last minute
however being that I am NOT a [ __ ] I
prepared for the worst
and so our ultimate Plan B was if we
couldn't get these spaces we would build
a set in the basement so that's what
you're seeing we're gonna be having a
space there's gonna be a little podcast
area and there's gonna be a shooting
space so that we can do shows it doesn't
mean that we're only gonna be doing you
know sit-down conversations I was like
I'm doing I'll probably end up moving
everything I do down there and have like
a real set behind me we'll see what
happens sub verse is gonna be primarily
focusing on a lot of the on the ground
report and like they've already been
doing so that's not going to change but
we're going to be expanding and that
means we need places where people can
work so for now the worst case scenario
is in the next five to six weeks this is
gonna be this is being built and by the
time it's done then we're gonna have a
new space to work and expand
unfortunately for this channel it means
that I'm not it's it's I can't just
leave right so when we started looking
at buying this building
I was stuck I'm also trying to find
somebody who wants to produce and travel
as a few people I'm working with and the
goal for the IRL channel this channel is
going to be traveling around a lot
during a 2020 cycle yes a bit of
politics I'll be talking to people you
know like you know we'll go to these
cities where the politicians are touring
we'll talk to people that's my ideal if
ideal it's what happens but also doing
some less political stuff right so we
will travel around we will follow
politics but every so often you're gonna
get hey our day didn't involve too much
politics I did all my shows on my
regular channels and then you can watch
us go to Dunkin Donuts or something this
is like regular vlog stuff right however
want to make sure we do a bit of travel
fun and explore interesting stories with
that one of one of the shows were
planning for the for the this new space
in this new podcasting space is gonna be
an unsolved mysteries show probably
co-hosted by me sometimes with some
other people and I'll tell you exactly
what I want to do with this channel and
the podcasts and expanding subversive
stuff have you noticed that like all
news all the time is somehow related to
Trump the orange man the culture war or
something everything's always about it
all the time like I open up the hill and
it's like Mitch McConnell and Donald
Trump and Nancy Pelosi I look at
BuzzFeed they're like we just did a
documentary tracking down white
nationalists and all this other stuff
you look at CNN that's what they're
hiring you look at Brian self the show
it's all the same thing over and over
and over again so here's what I'm hoping
we can do with summer so we'll see what
happens covering stories that aren't
about politics like you know what
happened to actually going and exploring
interesting characters character-driven
stories maybe there's a guy who lives in
the woods who's like experimenting with
energy weapons for a weapons contractor
nothing to do with the apocalypse in
riots and civil war and trump and none
of that just like interesting stories
where we meet like you know the the the
jungle man of you know northwest oregon
and it's a guy who like Tarzan is weird
stories you know just interesting things
about the world
everyone's getting super wrapped up in
the same narrative so that's one of
things I'm hoping for and that's not
another thing we're doing with this
unsolved mysteries show so we actually
have a script we've had it for a while
and we did set up a podcasting room but
again like getting the space built in a
set design is consuming all of my time
outside of actually look I record an
hour and a half every day I do all the
research and then after that I'm dealing
with this but the unsolved mystery
show's gonna be great did you know that
a couple months ago in Oregon Northwest
Oregon is why I mentioned it right some
cattle ranchers noticed their bulls a
couple of them were completely
exsanguinated and had body parts
surgically removed and blunt force
trauma on the underside of their body if
that means something drained their blood
removed body parts with precision
surgical precision and then drop them
from a large height how does that happen
it's weird right so the idea is we're
not going to be some kooky conspiracy
nonsense it's going to be like skeptical
rash
conversations around these stories and
that story as you know is tied to the
Chupacabra legend but it's still
happening so we want to do a kind of
timely relevant series where we'll talk
about mysteries you know be it like
murders ghosts whatever aliens just
interesting ideas and the idea is to
bring a few people on some skeptics some
some idealists some dreamers some
conspiracy people where we can have an
interesting conversation between someone
like me who is very skeptic you know
very skeptical of all these stories and
would say it's not aliens it's more
likely to be a cult or you know
someone's stealing body parts makes more
sense and then having some you know
kooky person be like nah man
aliens right just for entertainment for
fun conversation so we're gonna be doing
that there's gonna be ideally some
interviews as well and that requires you
know a booking person so again it's all
comes down to we the space we need
workstations we've got a couple
workstations now set up now we need the
production space so we wanted to buy a
building you didn't work we're now gonna
resort to using my house as a temporary
you know hold and then hopefully in the
next six months or so we actually do get
to expand to that building and then
actually start bringing out a lot more
people that's when things start getting
fun 2020 is gonna be a really really big
year for politics so I don't want to act
like we're not gonna do any of that
we're certainly going to do it but you
may have noticed that if you go to sub
verse you're not gonna get inundated
with orange man stories be at orange man
good or orange man bad or Nancy Pelosi
good or antsy blows you bet no no no no
you're gonna find people going on the
ground in Hong Kong Barcelona France and
that's what we're looking to do we're
looking for for a lot more of that so
you know I will say although I'm not in
charge of editorial for what sub vs.
doing I'm definitely going to be
allocating as much as I can towards it
so one of my missions with this channel
as well we're gonna be on the road and
you may actually see behind the scenes
of like a mini documentary productions
like I mentioned earlier we want to do
stories for the mini docks that aren't
about the apocalypse and a national
level politics and culture maybe just
like character-driven stories and so the
behind the scenes stuff while we're
going and producing it might appear on
this channel that's like another another
mission so I will say I apologize for
you know not getting on the road and
doing the van channel like I wanted it's
it's it's priorities you know I think
the most important thing I can do with
my time is make sure the mission of
producing fair and balanced news
I said that on purpose you get the joke
but but you know to the best of our
abilities takes it takes precedent so
you know you've seen the clips of the
basement it's getting built in the next
five or six weeks we're gonna have a set
everything's gonna be more professional
prettier it's gonna allow us to expand
it's gonna allow us to license content
there's a lot of reasons why the content
I produce on YouTube can't be used by TV
networks and so if we can expand that we
can generate more revenue hire more
people and that's the process of doing
business so for the time being
I'm stuck stuck in my house filming as I
was no longer in the theatre we need our
own space it's very complicated but in
the end it's the best we can do so if
somehow you've managed you to to make it
this long subscribe to this channel I
know a lot of people are upset here's
your update and I apologize that you
know look by not getting on the road
causing actually causing problems I got
a winterize the van now which is
unfortunate the van is built and now I
can't just hop in the van and use it
because I have obligations and I think
we've got a bigger play at hand but the
good news is we haven't stopped the
underground reporting some verses been
you know turning it out and doing those
those you know none orange man reports
I've been doing everything I've been
doing we've been working as hard as we
possibly can to make sure we can expand
this right and here's your latest update
day one of construction it's been so so
let me just wrap this up when we started
when I start preparing the van channel
it's the same time I started entering
negotiations for some properties at the
same time we started working on the
plans for the house so that we knew if
one fell through we'd have the other
sure enough the sale fell through I'm
very you know I'm kind of upset about it
but it is what it is at the same time
though permitting process negotiation
you know all the stuff that had to be
done was done and now seriously two
months later we've broken ground on the
first phase of getting this done so
thanks for hanging out here's your
update I'm gonna try and get this
channel updated as soon as I can
I'm talking with a few people to produce
vlogs we've got some cool stories
planned
trying to do it but I'm not gonna do a
vlog of like me just sitting here all
day reading those so so this would you
get thanks for hanging out I will see
you all next time and I'll let you know
when this channel gets more updates but
hopefully we'll be soon
adios